Without any other questions or items do we have a motion to approve consent what's approved all in favor aye opposed
Stentions motion carries five zero
item 16 a
Public hearing to consider master application number
202 6 9 general plan amendment
number 2 1 0 1 change of zone number 2 1 0 1 tentative partial map number 3 9 0 1
Conditional use permit number 2 1 0 1 and site development permit
SDP number 2 1 0 2 to allow a recreational vehicle RV and
Self-storage facility on an 86.8 acre site located southeast of I-15 and 68th Street
APN's number 152-0 6 0-0 6 1 5 2-0 6 0-0 6 0-0 7 1 5 2-0 7 0-0
8 1 5 2-0 6 0-0 0 9 1 5 2-0 2-0 2-0 1 0 1 I mean 0 1 0 in the applicant Steve Gonzalez
Senior planner Renaldo Aquina. May we please have staff report
Good evening Mayor Brickson and fellow council members
So tonight's public hearing it as the mayor mentioned it in regards to
an I-15 freeway addition to the I-15 freeway for a vehicle and self-storage site
In terms of the project location what you see here is the overall
City of group of alley and in the red star there you'll see kind of the location of this project site
So it's a towards the south western portion of the of the city right along the Santa Ana River
These are more focused in view of the site
So in red is the perimeter of the city of group of alley and in blue is the
perimeter of the project site
For today in terms of the north of the project site you have 68th Street right adjacent to that project site
further north you have Pat's Ranch Road and
South or sorry west of of that project site you have the I-15 freeway
and
Directly north you have the River Bend community there
This is just a view from 68th Street looking towards the project site as you can see is that axis road there
That's that's part of the project site
And so it gives you an idea of how it looks now
You can see it's currently chain link fence
But with if it does get approved, then you know this will be all improved
There's a these are a few views from within the project site
So if you start to your left, this is a view along the access road that's leading directly to the project site
The access road is about 2,000 feet long
And then if you move to the far right on the top is the view
To the eastern portion of the project site from you could say from the I-15 freeway
Looking east and then the bottom view there is a view directly south to the project site
So you see there's the tree line. That's kind of where the habitat riparian
That is this current located in Santa Ana River
How this is a kind of a the site plan of the overall or conceptual plan?
It is a little small reason why is it the site is pretty long. So just to kind of orientate you
What you see to the top is 68th Street all the way to the top and then moving south you have the axis road
That's a mention to tell about 2,000 feet long and then you hit the project site
Towards the south of that axis road there
And so in red is the building or the self storage building about 136,000 square feet
to the east of that you have the RV parking the borough area
Which I'll be talking a little bit more in the following slides and in directly south you have that conservation area
72 about 72 and a half acres currently
And then directly adjacent to the west side of the project site you have a flood control channel
leading
Next to kind of the Caltrans area and then you have the I-15 freeway there
There's a more focused in view of the actual project site
So I can mention is about overall 86.8 acres if you break that down
It's within two parcels the most southern parcel being the kind of the conservation area
It's about 72 and a half acres
Lot one which is the what it which encompasses the source of storage building the RV parking what you see that they're on the right image or the exhibit
is about 14.3 acres and
To kind of go more in detail for for lot one here. So in red is
The again, this is the self storage building 136,000 square feet are on there
Directly east of that you have the RV parking which consists about 77 stalls of RV parking in yellow
There's also overall parking which consists for about 19 parking spaces and those are in orange
So it'll be right to the north of the self storage site
That's about seven stalls there and then directly west of the storage. So you have 12 parallel parking
stalls
To move along we have directly to kind of the east of the RV parking you have a what's called the borrow area
So that site is about three point three acres
Plus or minus and so that borrow area primarily will be needed to
To take dirt and use it to lift
The self storage building and the site from the flood area, which is currently in right now
That'll be the primary for the borrower. What what will be used for?
And secondary will be considered after the dirt is taken now. It'll be more of a water quality management system
Hydroceded it'll be hydroceded and also will be used for any flood water
That that comes through the rains will be able to go through to that area there
In terms of surrounding that borrow area, there's an access easement that will be used for to kind of to maintain that borrow area
To the north and then directly east of that borrow area
Also, you have a pump house which I'll be talking a little bit more about
Further in the presentation that's directly north of that eastern RV parking area. So that's a pump house there
And then if you move to the western RV parking directly north you have a
RV dumped station right along there and that RV dumping was
Requested by one of the planning commissioners during the PC hearing which was which the applicant went ahead and added in this case
And so that's kind of the overall area for the project site and again
Directly south of that project area is a 72 and a half acre preservation area
site
In terms of landscaping
The applicant is it's going to be providing about 63 trees throughout the project site
And to kind of orientate you the exhibit on the left side is the access road cut into
Multiple into three sections because it's so long right so
Starting at 68 Street here in the top as you could see so there's going to be the extra will be about 60 foot wide
But from curb to per to curb will be about 35 feet with 12 feet to of landscaping to the west and 12 feet of landscaping to the east
And so the reason why the the extra is so wide is per fire
So since they don't have two access
Roads, they're only using one to the project site
They asked that the access road be wide enough for firefighters to come in and come out of that site
No parking will be allowed on that access road as well. So
Leading with landscaping as you could see on the west side of that access road is most of those trees
The east portion there is right adjacent to the river bend community
And that section the east section those are existing trees landscaping that is maintained by the river bend community currently
And so if we go down to the actual project site
That's where you see then the rest of those trees over 63 trees that are sprinkled kind of throughout the site
There so on the west side next to the I-15 freeway and then you have to the north side there and then the borrow area
as well
In terms of business operations for the project site in terms of hours of operation, it's divided into two
So the self-storage portion and the RV storage portion
Starting with a self-storage hours of operation that are being proposed is 8 a.m. 211 p.m. Monday through Saturday
and 10 a.m. 211 p.m. on Sundays
In terms of the RV storage
It's from 8 a.m. To 6 p.m. Monday through Saturday and 10 a.m. To 5 p.m
Sundays
The overall site will have about five employees
throughout the day
And in terms of 24, there will also be a 24-hour camera surveillance for the entire site
There will be working 24 hours and then you have
kind of security gates, which I'll be talking a little bit more on the next few slides
But you have security there will be some gates and a at 68th Street
There'll be one and then you have another gate
right before you hit the overall project site at the end of the
access road so
To kind of give you an idea if we go back here, so there'll be a gate right along 68th to the north
And then another gate right at this and right before you hit the project site so two gates
And those gates will be code access gates
So
There'll be people that come in and out will need to have
Storage units on the site of that's the case. So these code access
access
Gates would only would only won't be available after 11 p.m. Sorry
But these gates do have Knox boxes. So in the case of emergency
Firefighters can go in and out of the site
In regards to security patrol, there will be security patrol from 10 30 p.m. To 11 15 p.m. Monday through Sunday
And that exhibit you see on the on the right side is kind of an overall area looking from the preservation
area towards the project site there
To talk a little bit more about the conservation area, which is a lot too in red that you see to the right there
So that area is proposed as conservation area swarma or the south was regional management agency will will continue to own that and manage that conservation area
And to further enforce that there is a condition of approval
31 that
Requires that swarma keep maintenance up for that site if this project does get approved
If it doesn't and then we could enforce that condition of approval in terms of maintenance of the site
There's a kind of a summary of the ownership timeline of the overall in terms of
When it was sold when it was bought by the applicant the applicant will provide a little more detail on that if needed
But to go in 2017 Steve Galvest and amc business ventures lp
Opened in escrow with june and smith trust
And that included all five parcels which includes the whole 86.8 acre site
On February 2019 Galvest and amc business
Ventures lp close the escrow on the five parcels
And then again in on june 2019 Galvest sold
About 72 plus or minus acres to swarma
And that's in the grant as part of the grantee that shows that information and then in the purchase agreement
That's part of the staff report as an attachment of surprise language on that
And then finally in terms of swarma, it's basically there they're a conservation agency
And what they dedicate themselves to is to preserving natural resources
There's a view of the tenant of parcel map to kind of orientate you
the north or 68th street is towards your east side there again the the reason why is a prite it's so long
But yeah, so that's your orientate to 14 acres are
This parcel here, which is going to be it's being proposed to be
Developed and then the 72 and a half acres of preserved open space
Another thing to add here
The tenant parcel map was requested because the overall site needs to be subdivided into these two parcels
Lot one and lot two
In terms of entitlements that are required for this particular project is a general plan amendment
To change portion from open space recreation to commercial retail
And that's within those 14 acres
The change of zone
It's in regards to from water course watershed and conservation or w one
Two general commercial see one cp in order to be consistent with cr there
And then again as I mentioned the tenant of parcel map is in order to subdivide that 86.8 acres site
Into two lots 14.3, which is the lot one that they'll include the self storage in the rv storage
And then the lot two being 72 and a half acres and that's what will be conserved and maintained by swarma
A conditional use permit will be required as well
And that's for the self storage portion of the project and a site development permit will be required
For the trailer and both storage portion of the project site
This is just the exhibits of the general plan land use in terms of existing. What do you see right now and what is being proposed
So as I mentioned
Currently the access road is mdr
with the overall
14 acres and 72 have acres being open space recreational
What they're trying to do is convert 14 acres of that or 11.5
to commercial retail
Zoning
Again, it's it's r4 the access road and w one in terms of the the rest of the project site
What they're trying to do here is
convert
The project site into c1 cp right and that's the only change there
In terms of analysis, the project must be consistent with the general plan
The project site is within the question left side of protection overlay
the senna and a river corridor overlay and the general it's it would need to meet the general plan's vision statement
In terms of the project site in terms of meeting those
The question left side protection overlay
The applicant is proposing that equestrian trail along 68th street
And which i'll talk a little bit more in the following slides
Then you have the senna and a river corridor overlay, which basically the states that it needs to be protected, right?
So the applicant is what he's doing is trying to push in terms of disturbance
to the furthest north as possible to not touch that
conservation area habitat area
And in terms of the general plan vision statement the applicant did provide a letter in terms of how they're meeting this
And it's part of the staff report attachments as well
Furthermore project must be consistent with the code requirements including the findings for entitlements zoning code and the subdivision code she do
and the bottom
Image there is kind of the image of the building from the 15 freeway
for a reference
We'll talk a little bit more about the floodplain and the line of sight here so to kind of orientate you the image below
shows
what sorry
What you have here on the river and commuting to the east right so
To the east you have about quite a few homes adjacent to that project site
and
West to that you have a 12-foot tall sound wall
Going west to that you have the question trail or a multi-purpose trail that's right adjacent to that sound wall
Followed by a steep slope which is about right now is about 20 feet
Down to ground level where the project site is currently situated
And so what you see there in terms of building height
It's being proposed to be about 28 feet tall two stories
And so in terms of line of sight it kind of gives you
What residents will be seeing from the question trail right and so
If you see there that's their line of sight when it comes to kind of the second story of those homes
They'll be seen basically the rooftop of that building our 28-foot tall building
In terms of the floodplain as I mentioned earlier
The applicant because it is within the 100 the 10 and 100 year floodplain currently
the applicant is proposing to
lift or or provide a lift for that building
And so it'll be about from ground level once it's lifted it'll be about 12 foot above ground
And that's where that will be to be outside of the floodplain in this case
There's a kind of improvements that are on 68th street
So as I mentioned 68 streams in terms of improvements is along the frontage of that axis road
Overall it'll be about 59 feet of improvements
That would include also
Towards the north of 68th street they're going to be adding kind of a left lane to get into this project site
Which would require to widen that northern portion
The rest of it will be about 29 feet of public right away within those 29 feet
You have 12 feet of equestrian trail and then you have about eight and nine feet on either side of landscaping
When it comes to the axis road
As you see there in terms of improvements to that or like I mentioned it'll be overall 60 feet wide
with
35 feet from curb to curve of concrete and then you have 12 feet on the west and east of landscaping
When it comes to walls and fencing as I mentioned there's going to be two fences one at the beginning of 68th street right at the entrance of the axis road
You'll have the next skate right south right before you hit the project site
and also
as part of a condition we were required the applicant to
Provide a rutiron fencing all along the access road to the west to replace what currently is at the site
Which is chain link and so the applicant was was willing to do that
And so the uh they'll be on the western
And then directly to the southern portion of the project site right before you kind of hit the conservation area
You do have another gate that will be used for
Swear my strong wants to kind of maintain that area and then access that preservation area
It's about 16 feet wide the gate and they'll be able to enter through that or you have another gate
Directly, I would say southeast of the site right along the borough area
That will be another entrance gate
They're just a little more detail on the walls and fencing
So all in red is kind of the overall site of the rutiron fencing that will be surrounding the project site or in the perimeter
And then you have
Again, as I mentioned on the western portion of that access road is rutiron as well
the reason why the applicant wanted to do rutiron fencing is just to
um because of the architecture of the building they wanted to he wanted to make sure that
Anybody on the freeway or passing through could see that that building with with with the architecture of farm style
These are the elevations of that particular business. I mentioned farm style
Architecture what you'll see directly from the freeway
Is this top portion here, right the western portion
and then
Image at the bottom gives you kind of like a rendering of what the the building could look like
In terms of building floor plan, uh, like I mentioned the building would be two floors
The first floor will consist of about 535 units of storage units and then the second floor would be
458 units
The pump house as I mentioned the applicant is going to be doing this in regards to
um
the reason why is
Fire required that the applicant provide two water access points
um
Since the applicant was not able to provide the second access point the fire recommended that they provide a pump house
Um, and so the applicant is is going to be doing that the pump house is about 28 feet tall
Sorry 27 feet tall one foot below what the overall building height is
And that will be directly adjacent to the rv parking site
In terms of environmental, um to provide some feed on terms of what happened during the environmental review
Um typically, um with an mnd, uh, it's got school to a public review
Public review period during that time all these departments being fish and wildlife
And all all their agencies are able to comment on the project to see if there's any concerns or issues with the project
Um during that public review period. There was no concerns from fish and wildlife
um, but on april 22nd
Right before a day before the pc hearing, um, we we did get a letter
From fish and wild wildlife stating that they had concerns and that they were preparing a letter
Uh with those concerns
Because of that reason on april 23rd. We recommended that pc continue the hearing, uh, which that did happen
It was continued, um, but the day after on april 24th fish and wildlife
Uh reached out to the city again stating that they did not have any concerns
Um and on june 15 and june 5th, sorry fish and wild life, uh provided a formal letter resending, uh, their initial concerns
Further on with the environmental, um as i mentioned in the initial mnd
Uh was uh part in march to through april of that public review period
Um, but further on through the pc hearings
It was found out that one some aprons were left out as well as
um
We did not notice a a nor a high historical high school in this case
So what we did in this, uh, we re noticed the mnd, uh, that was done in around june
And to make all those corrections, uh, that was re-notice
And no comments came back in terms of some departments commented but sequel was able to kind of answer to those comments which
uh, sico could probably talk a little bit more about that later on in the presentation
And then finally the part of the requirement mnd, um, and, uh, mitigation measures were proposed or required in order to reduce
Uh, uh, the impact so less than significant significant for the project site
And so these mitigation measures are part of the project that will need to be met
Uh, if it does get approved, uh, through the building stage before that happens
In terms of public comments, uh, we see about over 20 public comments so far up to now
Um, some of the reasons stated reasons for support of the project were, um, that, uh, the resident's need for rv and self storage facility to address
Uh, the legal dumping and lack of rv storage. Um, the architecture design, uh, it's it's it's great
Uh, minimal impact in large to large conservation areas
And we'll provide street improvements, uh, along 68 street, uh, on that side
In terms of concerns, uh, from the public comments is property ownership, uh, right? That was one of the concerns
Which again mentioned the applicant could tackle a bit more about that in detail
Uh, potential impacts to proposed conservation area a lot too and all the habitat portion of that
And then also that the project may create environmental issues to the habitat and site
In terms of planning commission's recommendation on november 12th, they did move forward with, uh, proposing approval
To this project site for city council to vote on that, uh, for on november 12th
And to next recommendation, uh, for city council is to conduct the public hearing and adopt resolution the ordinances approving the entitlements for the i15
Rv and self storage project and adopting, uh, the environmental impact report mitigation monitoring and reporting program
And that concludes, uh, the the presentation as mentioned i'm available for questions
Our sequel consultants are here as well as well as the applicant. All right, very good. Thank you for the report
Uh, i'll turn to my colleagues to see if there's any questions for staff
If I could i've got a comment to make before we get to that point
Yep, go ahead
I received a letter dated january the 29th 2026 from the attorney for the applicant
Demanding that council member carmona not participate in the council's consideration of these land use approvals
The attorney claims that the council member carmona had improperly
Expressed as opposition to the project before the public hearing
By stating that it was a threat to protected open space in social media posts
In my opinion council member carmona may participate in the council's action this evening on the i15 self storage project
I have researched the law and found no legal reason that would require
council member carmona to step aside and not participate in this matter
California law is clear that when it comes to legislative matters such as general plan amendments zone changes specific plans or development agreements
council members may express their views on such land use
Applications or support or oppose the applications before the required public hearing
These are important land use policy matters that concern the entire community and define the direction of the community
The courts have stated that with respect to legislative matters
The council member not only has the right but the obligation to discuss issues of vital concern with their constituents
And to state their views on matters of public importance
Here are the comments of council member carmona relate to the application the applicants
Application to change the general plan land use designation
Of its property from open space recreational to commercial and to change the zoning on its property from water course
Watershed and conservation areas to commercial
Um, these are both legislative actions and council member carmona isn't taught up by law to express his view on these matters
Prior to the public hearing and to solicit the views of his constituents
The application also includes a conditional use permit for a self-storage facility that is quote ways
Adjudicative in action or need of the courts
These types of actions require more neutrality by a council member prior to the public hearing
Here, however council member carmona did not comment on the self-storage facility
But express concern about the conversion of open space to commercial use
The proposed change in commercial use would allow many types of commercial projects in addition to the stealth self-storage
Facility that do not require conditional use permit
The stealth self-storage facility cannot be approved without the change in the general plan and the change in zoning to commercial
Therefore, as I said earlier the law does not require council member carmona to step aside and not participate in the council's consideration of the application
And that's the end of my report. Thank you for the update and clarification. I know
I know we saw we saw the the emails coming about that issue and i'm glad you were able to research it and come up with
The legal conclusion. So we are in full five members to listen to this. Yes. Okay. Let's move on
All right now we're going to turn
To questions by council for staff. Anybody have questions for staff?
Well, that's that's fine. We'll get to that in a sec. I
Got some questions for staff always then go ahead. Thank you, sir
Um
I'm more to come on that letter. I'll I'll I'll bring that up in a moment
um
Thank you very naldo and joe and and uh and ernie for being part of this. I have a couple questions. So
I want to just clarify a few things and some of this we've already spoken about and so I just want to
Get it on the record. Uh, just so there's clarity here from
Um from our residents and just myself and my colleagues. So one is is this issue of ownership
uh one of my biggest concerns
Uh because I received a number or I think we all received a number of letters about
You know folks questioning ownership and like what's going on? What's what's the price? So
I looked into it and and based on our understanding and correct me if I'm wrong, but um
From from our read mr. Gelves purchased the 88 acres
Um a couple years ago, right purchase those
While he owned the whole property the whole 80 years he applied for this self-storage container
self-storage warehouse, right? But that's one of the first part
um the second is
then
A portion of it a large portion of it. I will say was purchased
Um through clothes of escrow and I have the purchase agreement here
Uh by south west resource resource management agency the purchase agreement
um
They purchased
A large or large chunk of that
Um as as well and and that closed in in 2019 I believe correct. Yeah, okay great
And as part of of that purchase from from southwest
Oh mess it up. I'm gonna say swarma
Um swarma
Is owned lot two
and then
Really all of lot one except for the entrance
Right because the the entrance which is just the the strip of land that
Continues to be mr. Gelves's property, but the rest is owned by swarma. Is that accurate? Correct. Yep. Okay, great. So, um
How much how many acres is the is that strip? What's that considered the mdr portion? That's about
Um give or take about two acres. Okay. So out of that 88 acres
88 ish acres
He owns currently in this moment those two acres
Right, so then currently swarma owns 86 acres or approximately I guess I would say yep
Okay, so that just wanted to lock that in so mr. Gelves
Owns currently two acres, which is what's zoned mdr
kind of
the entrance if you will that strip but then the majority of lot one which is the
The
The site that we're discussing now where he wants to build that site is currently owned by the conservation company
Correct. Right. Okay. So then part of their purchase agreement
is
if if
This applicant is able to get this approved
Then that lot would go we basically take it out of the conservation
Agency and then it would go into the private
You know his private hands. He would own it specifically is that accurate and then if you want to give any context feel free
That that's accurate. That's accurate. Okay. Cool. Okay. So, yeah, that was my my first concern
So that sale
Has already closed the escrow has already ended. We have the purchase agreement. We we looked at the ownership
So currently lot one the majority of it is in us owned by the conservation group
That's the first thing I wanted to establish the other
is
Regarding the mitigated negative declaration. So
Ernie, you're you're up, sir
My understanding is that this is more of a mid-level environmental review and that the EIR
Is a higher level is that a basic understanding of what the mitigated negative declaration is?
Yeah, yes, it is a when an application comes forward under CEQA
We do what's called an initial study
And initial study has all the technical reports to go with that whether it's an EIR whether it's a mitigated negative declaration
Those are your air quality noise biological
Cultural noise everything is all in that application
And then once we take that application and we review those materials
We go through what's called the initial study checklist
And we that's the decision point was there impacts that were
Potentially significant and if they can be mitigated to less than significant
Then you can adopt
Either you have the choice of doing the mitigated negative declaration
EIR is only required when effects are so significant that they can't be reduced
They can't be mitigated. So can you repeat that part an EIR is only required if
If they have significant impacts, it cannot be mitigated. That cannot be mitigated. Okay. One of the things that I think people
that aren't involved in the the details of this type of work is that
EIR the mitigated negative declaration isn't necessarily lesser
They all start out from the same point
Application submitted technical reports technical reports are the foundation of the secret review process
It's required that any decision any information in that document has to be supported by substantial evidence
And that's defined in the law with substantial evidence. It is it can't be somebody's opinion or whatever it has to be technically based
Substantiated evidence that the that the lead agency which is the city council
Takes and they look at that so they both kind of start out of the same place
Sometimes you know you're going to have an EIR because it's just so big
Like the district you wouldn't even bother to wear house mitigated neg deck for that because of the size of that project but projects that are
Different or not not as big for say you put it through the first layer and go through that process
And that's what happened here. So there is there isn't anything that was done less in terms of biological resources or any of the
Impacts on the environment that you would do
But the EIR does it elevates it to a point where
You can't mitigate it and then it becomes a value decision of the council if there is for example an impact that cannot be mitigated
It's significant and unavoidable
You can adopt a statement of overriding considerations and says you as the city council
Have decided that even though this project is going to have this effect on the environment
Say it's air quality for example or whatever
Then you have the ability to consider your values as a community and say that you're going to override that
So let me ask you this Ernie. Um, can you can you explain?
On our record on our public record how it was determined that there was no substantial evidence in this project
That's going to have a significant environmental impact. I got how did you determine that?
To be able to require
A full environmental impact report because I've seen an environmental impact report
And maybe i'm wrong
But i've seen it be required for what I consider as things that are less impactful housing units or or different different
Commercial projects that are much smaller in scale. Yes. We've had that we've had two recent focused EIRs for the wine bill project
We had some others too or one for the airport an airport property that was incompatible with the airport land use plan
So you can have five acres that's subject to an environmental impact report. Just matters what the issue is so specifically here
What was the substantial evidence that you found that said this doesn't require?
Yeah, the substantial evidence was that this this property as is part of
Well, let me say this the city is a participant in what's called the western
regional conservation authority. It's um, it's called RCA
WRM SHCP. There's a multiple species habitat conservation plan that covers all of south all western riverside county
And that plan is overall goal is to preserve sensitive biological areas and so forth. So that's the whole purpose of it
It's been around for a while
now
When you they have divided the area into
Cells they call them criteria cells. So if you're in a criteria cell, which this property is
But we're all like a text like a credit like credit cells
No, it's a criteria criteria cell. It's just a delineated area on a map that says this area
needs to be considered for
Taking into the the conservation plan
It's eligible on the surface to be
Considered for conservation. So it's in the criteria cell
So what we do is the planning department
We see that and we're obligated under the agreement that we have as part of the being a member
Is that we have to require what's called a joint project review?
So let's jump in just a little bit more directly
How how did you determine that there wasn't substantial evidence that
And yeah in terms of the impact so it wouldn't require a full EIR
We as part of the process when you're in we're in that we required biological studies habitat assessments
Or different species. There's multiple
Technical biological reports that we're preparing specifically. Yes, specifically. Okay. Um habitat assessment
So in my other question
Given given how close this is to the river and to the san ena river
Um, what was was that analyzed as a as a sensitive environmental setting under sigma? Yes
So the process is we form we file the joint project review application with the riverside conservation
Authority agency
We're up. We are the applicant. We are the committee. So we have to submit this along with the technical reports along with
All the technical reports and a finding
Because in a finding be made so it goes to them and they review all these biological reports
As part of that process they also consult with the california department of fishing and wildlife
And they consult with the u.s. Fish and wildlife service
So there's those three agencies are involved and they are the you know the experts in biological resources
So it's a process that we go through if they determine
that that
That in this area certain land has to be they want to take it
From you they'll have to go through a process and buy it from you and do that type of thing or it can be dedicated
but in this case
They decided that
They approved the joint project review
They said that of this acres this site that the 16 acres or 14 for the the self storage and the road of course
Could be
Taken they don't need it for conservation. It wasn't as biologically sensitive as
the other part. There's a lot too
so they approved
A situation where 72.5 acres could be conserved
The other one they didn't see is higher at high enough value per se
So that's how that process worked
But when i'm reading the the mitigated negative declaration
I I see constantly that many of the identified impacts because we identify a number of impacts
Um, so saying that there's no impact. I don't know, you know, I
Based based on the document. I would disagree based on your document
Um, but but a lot of those are mitigated through
uh
Through
through our conditions of approval and and specifically through future mitigation
So i'm wondering how did how did you come up with that?
The lesson significant required first of all
One of the mitigation measures is that you're going to impact these biological resources on this property
You have to compensate for it. You have to replace it. You just can't
Take it and do nothing. So that's what the
The acquisition of the land does you've either it preserved this in place
What what what about the technical comments on the on the hydrology?
And the river adjacent impacts because some of those talked about some serious impacts and and we we basically said
that they we we gave a
Statement saying we don't think those are significant the
Through the process
The western river side conservation plan has guidelines and requirements in place and there's something called the urban interface or the interface
So there's there's a there's a kind of county matrix assessment
Yeah, so you have this interface. So what we look at we have technical reports talking about
Would the development of this property affect the wildlife that's on there with lights with noise
With the adjacent resource be impacted by drainage
And so for those are all evaluated
To determine
If this development would have impacts on a adjacent area
How was it?
Analyzed in relation to our general plan because when when I read the mitigating negative declaration
We're missing at least three sections from the general plan the cos 2.2 8.2 8.3 that specifically say that
If we're going to build in this area
It should only be in extreme circumstances. It should only be
You know if if it's highly needed or in extreme circumstances
And I saw a lot of those areas missing from I'm glad you asked that question because
That gets to the core of what sequel is
so sequel
The council if this is a general plan amendment the council can make whatever decision they feel
Is appropriate. You're not bound by the consequences of the environment on this. So what I'm saying is that
You you make the policy and we tell you what the environmental of the effects on the environment are going to be by that policy
That's what we're telling you so
By all the laws and standards and analysis that you do to determine if biological resources are impacted
And you have mitigation measures and are they appropriate and they meet all the requirements the answer is yes
Those impacts have been evaluated thoroughly and as far as compliance with sigma. It is
Lesson significant. Okay. You're able to say
I agree. I don't agree and do because it's a legislative act. It's a I appreciate that. So basically what you're saying is
Yes, there are there are going to be impacts. Correct
sequel
And and just our analysis is is basically trying to outline which ones those are and how big they are
But at the end of the day
And and I think I think I appreciate your your your explanation Ernie at the end of the day
This is going to be this is fully discretionary
We're not mandated by the state to approve this or to build this
And we get to decide here on the council we have the the privilege of saying
Yes, it may have impacts if there's interest in building up, but we can mitigate them in one way or another, right?
That's a layman's way of summarizing that
One way to to look at this in terms of the biological resources is
There is going to be
No impact or means you have less than significant impact
On biological resources because lot two is conserving the resource
That's the first thing most of it is avoid minimize don't affect it
In this particular case
That has been accomplished for this
What the biologists have said is the sensitive habitat on this property. So lot two
It's going to be natural open space. It's not going to be disturbed
And then we have to look at well, how's the adjacent development going to affect that because they're going to be lights
Is they're going to negotiate that so we went through that process through that process was determined
That the 14 acres on lot one
Was not
Subject to mitigation it wasn't a significant resource if there wasn't anything there that was
You know couldn't be less than what about fema. We haven't got any response from fema
On the l o mr letter
Is that is that a requirement is that something we're going to have to wait for that's a flood control
City engineer issue at flooding map
I mean we do look at flooding like how they're going to control off site drainage on this property and they've done that
You know, they're not going to they're going to maintain the drainage on the property
No, this is great. I appreciate it. I think this is helpful
I think that's that's my questions on on seek. I have more but we I don't want to put everyone to to sleep
I'm gonna so my other question is
in terms of the the general plan amendment
and the
General plan land use so I'm looking at their grading
Plan and application and it states that the the land use is open space conservation
Um, so the the application that they they submit it which is in our staff report
Identifies that lot as open space of conservation, but I know we we
Identify it as open space residential which one is it open space recreation or was our are we are we sure about the how how can we be?
Sure about that because I know open space conservation would would have much higher thresholds in terms of the environmental review and requirements
So that's per the the land use map that we use
And that's kind of what the area is currently as stated per for that map. Okay. Thanks for the look. Yeah
You good? Yeah, okay, then we
are going to move
To public comments. We'll start this off the developer project developer gets 10 minutes for his entire team to present their
To present their project to us and then we will move to the rest of you who have about 50 of you are requesting to speak tonight
so
three minutes apiece times 50
We'll talk about that if you in about 10 minutes
so mr
Galvest your sir. They begin
Okay, thank you very much for taking me and
Distinguished mayor and council members. My name is Steve Galvest and I am the owner of the site
And now all I can ask for right now is that we have an opus honest and fair hearing that's all I've ever wanted
so
From that point on I want to thank the staff vernaldo. I mean we've done a Herculean job mr. Parea
Joe
Manny
Kevin Carr wherever you are right now
I mean it's just it was just a Herculean chance to get us where we're at if you see the building that I you have in front of you
That is the was designed specifically to honor old muraloma equestering heritage
It's it cost me a lot of extra money for the elevation architecture and that's the reason why as mr
As reynaldo said
We want to do the rod iron fencing because we want to show off the architecture
So if we go to slide two, oh, I got it right here. Yeah, perfect
This this property has a long history and this is a very simple slide, but i'm just going to really try to go through it very quickly
um
In 2016 2017 I was just going to buy the top parcel with the two access rows and do the self storage facility
After reading the general plan
2017 general plan vision statement
So and the elpo
A lot of consternation a lot of risk on my part
I decided to purchase the whole thing
Because I think it would be a better project for the city
Preserving space for the city for the elpo peel
So a question people can have a place to ride the horses forever in perpetuity. So I made that decision in 2017
Purchase the property went into escrow with mr
Julian Smith who owned the whole thing. I think even when parts of river bend at that time or before that
um
And I proceeded to do
biological studies
I did biologic studies for two years. You didn't hear about me for two years. I did
But what um habitat is present what habitat could be present
Um the potential for habitat. We did also what's called a jurisdictional delineation
to figuring out what is
valuable habitat and what is not you can see from the slide from the left
You could almost see the outline of my my property line. It was a tomato field in 2013
That aerial is from google earth 2013 and you can see it was a tomato field
Um, even today when we do the weed abatement, we still get the um
the drip lines in our in our
tractors
so in 2019
I did the deal with swarma
And yes, they do own lots seven eight nine and I own the two access roads
I we did that purposely
So that one the tpm the tentative parcel map or the lot line adjustment. Whatever you want to call it gets approved
They're obligated by comp by the purchase agreement to d back the 14.29 acres to me
the access road is actually 2.72 acres
if the tpm doesn't go through
They're going to be landlocked and that's going to cause a problem
So that was like my safeguard to enforce that they do their purchase the sale agreement
And they are they've been very cooperative. They're they're a professional organization
They own about 15 000 acres Riverside County. The main objective is to protect the Santa Ana river bed
So in 2019 I sold
that 73 acres to swarma
and
in April of 2020, I submitted a par
in
December of 2020 I submitted my full application
And then we had a public planning
session
Uh in july of 21
And then we did extensive outreach
So everybody keeps asking me why storage?
doesn't produce tax revenue
But it produces a need
We're underserved in the area
be um
I back in 2017 I studied the plans that were on the on the table
And I knew about vernola. I knew about the apartments. They weren't built yet. River said river bend was under construction
Uh, I knew about the specific planned up north of us. That's under grade now
So that's what decided me to to go with um
self storage
Currently now there's 400 apartments in front of me
um
3% of the residents in a three mile radius are renters 64 homeowners
uh putting self storage on high value commercial doesn't make sense
Um, you want to put it on low value commercial
Because you don't want to put it where an Aldi or uh trader jose can go because that can produce a lot of tax revenue
Uh, the storage is low impact. Okay. I'm going to produce 22 at the peak trips per day
Which is nothing and that's one of the reasons for an m&d and not any IR. There's very little impacts
uh, there's a lack of um adequate rv and rec rest of storage in the area
I'm in communication with the um river bend h oa
And um management company and they have um illegal rv parking. So they are in favor of me getting
uh rv parking on the site
We had a lot of ideas that
um
Didn't work and uh, I wanted to just quickly go through those
We had um
We were going to dedicate the land to the parks department
They didn't want it because they were over parked as it was and the cost a question in staging area
We talked to a lot of question in community question trails community
Park and parks department. They couldn't maintain it
We were looking at community gardens
Uh, we were told by the parks department that uh, that will just turn into a we feel and homeless encampment
I did get two l. O. I's for organic waste composting
But I know the neighbors would even hate that even more
Uh east fail had a crick crickets club that they wanted to put in but that would cost too much traffic
uh sports facility too much traffic and then
We were just thinking about a nursery but cross-pollination would not be good with the um with the uh protected open space
Um
I'll just go to the next one because we're not able to cover that
This is really what you can see from the ground level. There's a 20-foot elevation
Between the ground level and the trail 21 feet of
Trail and then a 12-foot sound wall and that's the view to the freeway
This is an important slide right here
Between
The front of my building and the back of their um the walls or 12-foot wall is 126 feet
The pitch of the roof the second pitch of the roof is 146 feet away from their line of sight, which is
I don't know. What is that 50 yards?
um
And there's only one house which i'll get to later
Right now and this is one thing I do
Respect you mr. Karmona is that you do endless cleanups along the river
Um right now i'm doing that. There's been trespassers illegal dumpers
My locks are constantly being cut video cameras are being stolen
Calls from code enforcement. I've done do cleanness about four to six times every year at my expense endless cycles to clean up
And I spent well over a hundred thousand dollars over the last eight years cleaning up the the site because the site responsibility is mine right now
um
When we're open for business, uh, it will add this will definitely will add a different the layer of security
This is what i'm dealing with. Um
That's the h2a company breaking down my fence and getting into the site
Stolen vehicles graffiti on the wall illegal dumping all over the place. I guess there was hunters at one point
We're not we're not able to set the site today taking pictures on 68th street and there's a homeless encampment. I just found out
So I got to deal with that tomorrow
This is a homeless encampment that was there and this is the trash that i've been cleaning up
I mean, it's it's a disaster. This is all falling on me once this goes to swarma
They'll be responsible because they are a
5013c organization and their mission is to keep the the senate
San n river clean and free of debris and homeless encampments and it's a big expensive that they have every year
apologize
So i'm in the middle of a negotiating h08 landscaping and access agreement with seabreeze management
Um
The site will act as a fire buffer right now. It's green because of all the rain we had those are weeds that will turn brown
And i'll be responsible for we debating that and if it was conserved land, I wouldn't be allowed to we debate it
Because I have to get a 1600 permit if it was considered cdfw land
We'll have fire suppression on the site. I still spoke briefly about tax generation
No, it doesn't produce a lot of tax. I will produce a lot of property taxes, but that that's
Uh, not one of the benefits
One of the major benefits of self storage facilities is that um
I'm gonna run out of time
One of the major benefits of self storage facilities is that it's a need
uh people of trade that don't rely on upon ai carpenters plumbers drywall contractors will use it
People who just have junk will use it home businesses will use it. It just provides the needs it gets rv's off the street
So it's just providing a need for the city
And then there will be 24 7 video service uh security on that and that security will be
Top of the line security it'll have the ability to zoom in and zoom out with high resolution
On the exterior of the building and the interior building plus i'll have a license plate readers
Every car coming in they'll read the license plate and the ai technology is so superior right now
That not only will it read the license plate
It will identify that license place belongs to the car and if there's any warrants attached to the license plate
So that's the type of security that we'll be providing for the area
You guys want me to quit
Okay, good 10 minutes is up and because of the number of speaker cards
We are going to stick to a very limited time frame. No, I understand all right. So, uh now we will move to
The general public comments and I will ask you because of the number of comments
I'm not we're not reducing the amount of time you have each person is entitled to their three minutes
But in the event that somebody's already said what you have to say
Uh, you can stand up and and just tell us we agree with the prior comments or something
So we can move through this a little quicker. It's up to you. You're all entitled to come up here
Uh, but if it makes it any easier or quicker
You're also in when I call your name
You can just stand up and and let us know that you concur with whatever was recently said with that
Yes, sir. Sorry quick question. I have some questions for
Uh the applicant no not yet. We we have to do this this
Then we'll get to that. Yeah
So, uh first is amanda swagger and pam waller you're up next so just be ready
Good evening mayor city council everyone in attendance. My name is amanda swagger resident of her valley
And someone who has a lot of interest in both self storage and the environmental impact in the area
I had the ability to survey the area after seeing the agenda
And saw the exact impact of what was presented by the main uh main presenter here
Homeless encampments trash and other issues have been a issue in that place for a number of years
The reality though is that this as we have mentioned self storage is a major need in our area
Doing a survey of our v storage specifically
Less than 20 percent of the self storage units available in our area house rv storage
The closest being all tech storage out in the group of valley area off of belgrave
But the reality is that our homes in the area do not have adequate parking for rv storage
As an rv owner myself and also an owner of a large trailer for our business
We see that we often need a place to store that rv when we're not using it in the area
The reality though is that the property there while it might impact the communities around it
Do not actually impact the area as much as people fear
As we said one of the major areas of of the issue there is the brush fire potential in the river bottom
The developer has shown that they are willing to mitigate the the impact of this in that way
By by bringing that type of facility in the area they bring security that will hopefully
Reduce the homeless population in the area
Having worked with self storage for a long time including my two units at dollar storage
Which is down the road from that facility which by the way is extraordinarily expensive
I see a clean facility without people coming in out all day
And I see a giant cleanup of that area
The reality ladies and gentlemen is that self storage is a need we needed the area
That area there is not being impacted as much people think
And the reality is it's time to use that land for something that's not just growing weeds
And ruining the area for everyone else. Thank you. Have a great night
Pamela you're up and next will be Jacqueline
Strengthen Taurus would be after this
Okay, sorry that somebody called me. Okay. Good evening. I'm here support the proposed RV self storage facility and highlights tangible impacts of recent residential development
The vernola project in the proposed diversified pacific project together will add nearly 2,000 homes within a quarter of a mile of each other
Much of this new housing consists of smaller lots with limited garage
Space and yard space which increases demand for off-site storage
This growth is occurring in the area that already experiences significant congestion limited on street parking and almost no lawful option for RV and trailer storage
These impacts are measurable today recreational vehicles and trailers are parked on the streets in driveways and in yards because they're
Few lawful alternatives residents are using garages for household storage rather than parking further increasing on street congestion
This reduces street capacity affects the emergency access and creates enforcement challenges as more homes are built
These conditions will worsen unless directly addressed the promote proposed RV and self storage facility provides a targeted low intensity solution
The self storage and RV storage are among the lowest traffic generated land
Use is particularly compared to the residential or the retail development
This project adds no residents generates no school demand places no material burden on utilities and produces far less daily traffic than housing or commercial uses
Most importantly it addressed existing conditions
Providing a lawful managed location with household RV and trailer storage relieving pressure on surrounding neighborhoods
From a land use perspective. This site is appropriate. It is located near a major transportation corridor
Buffered with existing homes and well suited for use that requires access but minimum daily activity
This project can be designed to meet all the apical general
Plan zoning and municipal codes. I recognize
Concerns regarding the minor zone change and the potential alternative uses
These concerns can be conditioned
Approvals specifically for RV and self storage
With any material change requiring a new application or return to council for review
This ensures transparency and council oversight and legal certainty
This project does not create new community impacts it mitigates existing documented challenges from rapid residential growth
Additionally, it retains storage spending local supporting jobs and the city's tax base
It is consistent with responsible land use planning and the city's objectives for orderly development
I respectfully urge the council to approve this project with appropriate conditions and thank you for your consideration
All right, uh jacklyn patris and after that will be christian garcia
Welcome. I don't have a speech prepared
Um, thank you for your concern because I agree as a resident of
I'm sorry
That got me worked up and I'm trying
Okay, I'm counting time
um as a resident of
Riverbend excuse me
We bought their brand new we have an excellent and very safe community
We already have AI where it reads your license plates going in and we do not have a problem with RV parking
And I think people who own rv's generally take on the responsibility of either buying a home with a large lot that can control that
Or they find a facility to store it and it might be expensive, but so are rv's
So I think it's the risk worth taking and you're right homeowners don't generally want to look at rv's
So
We are happy that we don't have that in our community
But I think of this as a residential area because when you leave riverbend the first thing that you look at is an elementary school
And I see kids walking down this we also paid
Our school taxes go to norco
As well as walking along that and I'm thinking the reason the gate is cut is probably for access for
Probably haroopa valley to keep it clean. I have never seen the trash. I have seen home encampments
On another note to keep this quick
I am a mother-in-law to a wonderful fireman who is an engineer. Also. I have other family
Uh who are also in the fire department when I think of cal fire
The fires that they are able to access go into the riverbed and the riverbed I grew up in Orange County
It is a big part of our community and we expect it to say that way and keep it safe for our environment
And when they say oh, we're just gonna fix it and do this and do that. We are already in a flood zone
We are already having environmental impacts with our breathing because what is today as another wind advisory air
quality alert
So we have all these other things going on and building another
Facility doesn't seem like even if you could fix it. You're taking away from our environment
I also have property in norco and I know weed abatement is really not that big of a deal
Um, so I think that keeping homeowners who have a lot actually paid extra to have these view lots
Are now going to be looking at a facility and if it's one home, you're saying one person doesn't matter
And these are not small homes. I think the smallest might be 2,400
Which might be very small to some people, but it is large to other people
um
I think that this should have been more of a consideration to the impact of the communities on both sides
Not just that and this was
Muraloma taken over by hoopa valley probably for the purpose that they didn't want the muraloma paperwork from what I heard earlier
Um
And you have an RV fan station there on my dad's birthday. Sorry
All right. I am done. I've yield my time and thank you. Thank you
Christian Garcia and after that will be Chandra Porter
Very good. Welcome all of you
Hello council, my name is kristin garcia
I'm here yet again to oppose this project and hopeful for a vote after almost seven years of this
This zoning is so critically important to the quality of life in harupa valley as stated in the general plan
I urge you to vote no and protect that conservation land and stay consistent with the goals clearly stated within it
Mr. Carmona you fight for our community and against predatory development
Please continue to do so by voting no
Mr. Silva as you can see the constituents in river bend just the ones we were able to knock on their doors clearly opposed this project
I hope you consider that when you vote no
Mr. Barajas. I see how active you are out in the community, especially at schools
Please consider the land loss for future generations and vote no
Miss santas in december of 24. You officially became a council member on your post on social media
You said you were ready to serve and preserve let's do exactly that and stop this
I hope you consider that when you vote no
Mayor bergsen
I know you have a background in real estate and construction and understand the long-term implications a project like this could have
Please consider that and vote no
I hope you all consider what would happen in the event of a fire in brush fueled by gasoline and propane
Stored inside of recreation of vehicles that isn't distinguishable by water alone only specialized foam
consider the 19 pages of
signatures from a petition that we received
of the residents who don't want this project
consider the equestrian overlay in the Santa Ana river corridor
Consider the measly three jobs that this building would bring in exchange for what
There is no benefit only destruction
I will end with this once this land is rezoned. It's gone forever
Ask yourself. Will this become another el camino rial
Stop this now. Please vote no. Thank you for your time
All right shundra porter and after that will be
Michael fits Gerald
Welcome. Thank you. My name is shundraia porter and my husband and I are
Proud owners in river bin
We bought our home in 2019 as a new build where the only people to ever live there
And we when we relocate it from los angeles county
We really thought that this was going to be our forever home
the open grassy area that this project is going to be in front of
Um is very beautiful for everybody that lives there river bin has about
460 some odd houses in our community and of the people that are sitting in here today that actually live there
We that live there we want you to vote no against this. We don't want this in our community
My husband and I we're actually glampers. We own a class a diesel pusher that we store off site
With this coming in our backyard. We're against it
Yes, it would give us someplace closer to park it
But all of the negatives that come along with it. We don't want that in our backyard
one of the things that I had a question of and hopefully someone can answer is
What are the impacts that the river river bin residents should expect and how will those
Impacts be mitigated. We haven't been told that
Everybody that's coming up that's talking about putting this storage facility in our backyard
Don't live there so they won't be affected in the way that we are that own property and that's our home
so
Representing our family and the rest of my neighbors in river bin
I would ask each of you to vote no tonight against this application. Thank you
Okay, thank you and
Michael for chilled. I'm Michael Fitzgerald. Thank you very much
I asked the community of river bin or the of ruba valley to vote no on this. I'm an avid cycler
I'm a community watching member. I'm on the in the river den area twice a day with my dog
The the panoramas the stunning views the seal behind you the seal that you represent is panoramic
It's what you see when you enter ruba valley. You see the panorama when you're on the 15 freeway
When you're going north or southbound, you see the panorama looking toward the san ant looking toward the um
the san ant river bed
It's it's a it's a draw to the community. It's it's beautiful. It's the last it's one of the last beacons
of
riverside that has
That type of panorama
The river bin park
There's a there's a position there at the river bin park where people
Take pictures because it's so panoramic. It's it's family oriented
But the biggest impact of this is not so much the panorama and the beauty even though the seal does
I don't see a seal says it has a picture of you know high mass lights and water towers and storage facilities
I mean how much more commercial are we going to be
But the biggest impact to this is
There's four stop signs and a stoplight
in the eighth of a mile
between
I want to say the end of the elementary school
and um
This I guess the second street coming to east vale on 68th street
there's four
Stop areas and then one of the stoplight pads ranch road
There's already a backlog of crazy traffic there and again like I said, I'm a cyclist there
I see all the traffic. I see all the kids. I see so many accidents already
Almost happening and happening in this court in this eighth of a mile area
The impact is I don't care how much lane you're going to provide a second lane to turning lane
It's going to be crazy
Because there would be would you turn left or turn right into that facility from going westbound or eastbound
It's an absurd and arrogant
That a facility of this kind would be built in this area. There are over six
facilities within a mile of this area of this proposal
That are over over a million square feet of storage space
empty warehouses
Edwanda
uh, bell grave
So why here why why why?
Rupa valley put it put in a rupa valley on edwanda where there's already
Facilities already existing over millions of square feet in these warehouses just empties in there
Please propose a no for this. Thank you
Thank you and next speaker jennifer toner and after that kevin garcia
Hi, good evening city council members. My name is jennifer toner and I live in the riverbank community
The riverbank community has been outspoken for six years and has stood firmly that we're opposed to this project
The landing question is already in conservation and it needs to stay that way
Like the builder just said he bought the road on purpose
To landlock the conservation nonprofit and to making a deal for the proposed site
Why is the builder trying to rezone the full acreage
And stating that he's going to give back a portion of conservation
When the land is already in conservation and owned solely by shawarma
This doesn't make sense at all
Actually, the project makes zero sense like I said for six years
There's been zero consistency with the planning of this project
Lots of wrong information given to the community of river bend and to others in harupa valley
The general plan was made to protect the watershed land so leave it alone and do not allow the destruction of this land and vote no
You as council members set the precedent for every builder
Walking into harupa valley
Wanting to rezone what was made to be off limits
Think about the future of this land and what it will become if it's rezoned
There is zero need for the storage facility to be built
Where it's supposed to be proposed and this facility sure does not warrant the change of the zoning
If you all knew of any builder trying to build in harupa valley that was trying to bribe a certain community
To sway them to vote for any project
You scare tactics stating that they would sell the land to someone else that would do worse
Or that they themselves would turn beautiful land into a lithium
Battery refinery and telling lies for all the year. Would this be a builder? You would want to represent a business here in harupa valley
Does that sound like harupa valley's motto
Does that sound like our pride for our city?
No, it doesn't
You all have a duty to do the right thing by the citizens of harupa valley and also to our community of river bend
Do the right thing protect this land and vote no. Thank you
Kevin garcia and then uh christian toner after that
Oh, kevin garcia gone christian toner not here. Okay, then we'll move to jackie
uh
Pittington. I hope I got that right. Okay, good
Good evening mayor and council members. Thank you so much for having me there
tonight. Uh, it's a pleasure
I am I've been here a few times to speak against with the planning commission
Um, I live in this beautiful city for about eight years now, but my family I represent them tonight last
I was here actually though speaking in front of the planning commission
I actually got cussed at for speaking my mind
From mr. Calvez's friends that don't live in river bend don't live possibly in harupa valley
And I take a pride offense to that because I'm just a concerted citizen
Trying to speak my mind and what's right for our citizenship like our our seal behind you beautiful beautiful land
Excellent intimidation aren't acceptable and I'm so I'm telling my ship my choice my children
Um
That it's not right and I'm here today again to speak regardless of what what may come right?
intimidation of of getting custody and those kind of things
It is a bit fishy no pun intended
That the california department of wildlife rescinded their letter of concerns the day before our planning commission meeting
Think about that and I would like you I would love for you to see their original concerns as to why they were rescinded
Please do what's right for harupa valley
Don't get don't go against the general plan
The long-term effects and environmental effects of this uh rezoning is a mistake
You don't know what's going to come what's going to happen if he then sells it to somebody else and you know
Once you change it, it's gone forever
Your general plan states emphasizes preserving a semi-rule as christian lifestyle with specific mobility corridors and walking and biking and writing
We just hope we just heard that he wants to move a question trail up to the 68th street away from his property, right?
There's been a lot of false narratives that have been thrown around here
Not quite sure why the applicant has always told residents that he's donating the land to to the conservative uh in circumservation
But we just found out that he only owns a portion of it
So what's what there's so many inconsistencies originally it was supposed to be six length six acres that he was going to build on
Then it was 14
We do not we're in river bend
We see so many things that are going on the access road of approximately 2000 feet right here next to the homes
One way in and out large rv's large
Moving vans in and out to 11 o'clock at night
Those are loud
All of that uh storage all of that gas propane 78 rv's next to a wild fire area
I don't think that's actually very smart at all. We had firefighters here that said even mr
Mr mayor was saying there's so many fires in our area, especially in the river bend
We understand that these this is this is a riverbed area, but I want to make sure that we understand that please
Do what's right for river for a group of alley
I want to make sure that last time there aren't one of the commissioner said that they well have one rv
It's not a big deal when you have 78 next to a fireplace next to actually a riverbed where that goes on fire
That's a problem. Please do what's right and vote. No, all right. Thank you
next is um madison pittington and then we'll be maria garcia
Welcome
Everyone good evening mr
mayor and council members
Um my family and I have lived in river bend community almost eight years
I'm here tonight to speak against the proposal to build a storage facility in this area
I've attended the previous meetings and while you've heard from many of the other voices on the other side
Um, I think it's important you hear tonight from someone who lives here a child whose witness firsthand have construction and development have affected this community
Many people may not realize how much children actually notice
I'm now a college student and i'm now here to say what I think i'm not here to say anything that you guys probably want to hear
I'm here to share my truth and I hope that it offers a different perspective before any decisions are made
Well development can bring benefits this particular location raises serious concerns for the safety and well-being of our residents
First this area is already extremely close to family homes
Adding large rv's and trailer storage buildings that's going to increase traffic noise congestion and
In a neighborhood that's meant to be peaceful and safe, especially for children and allergy
That's not going to add to it
We've already seen how construction on 68th has created traffic hazards
This project would only add to the flow of cars and people making the area even more packed and dangerous, especially with a school traffic
It's insane already beyond belief
Um, if we want to improve these traffic patterns, this is not the way to do it
More importantly this location is known for fire outbreaks building structures like this in a high fire risk zone puts lives property and emergency responders at risk
Um, as I've lived here remembering the major fires
The fear that I've had with ash falling from the sky stepping out of my home
Seeing that the home that I I live in may not survive and the stress of wondering whether we have to evacuate
And wondering how we're going to rebuild our lives as our home that we've built is by fires
Those experiences stay with someone. Why would we choose to build new infrastructure in a place where fire danger is already so high
Yes new development like apartments that we've seen can be beneficial, but only for certain groups
Some of the people here today speaking don't face the same fire risk or traffic issues
We do they may be upset that river bend was built because they felt they took over their land
However, our community was also part of a plan just like everything else is
It isn't fair to direct frustration at residents who are simply trying to keep their families safe
I have nothing to gain from arguing with people. I don't know
I'm here because I care for this community and I live in it
Instead of investing in construction that increases risks. We should focus on smart planning
Um planning that protects our residents reduces fire hazards and keeps our community safe
You've seen how hard these firefighters have worked to stop these fires. Why are we going to add more obstacles in their way?
I urge you to please reconsider this project and explore safer locations that don't put homes and families at risk
Let's not put something here to make the city look better. Let's prioritize well being and security
As I'm living here with my siblings
I don't want them to be scared of the risk that I was with the fires
I don't want to increase the fire hazards
Thank you for listening. I appreciate all of your time truly
And I hope you keep our community safe and do what's right and say no to this plan. All right. Thank you
Next Maria Garcia and then after that Scott Smith
Do we have Maria Garcia
Is it Mario it it may be
I've changed your name just for tonight. All right
Welcome
Hi, I'm Mario Garcia. I live in the riverbank community. I'm here to oppose this project
By approving this project you will be opening the door for any developer
To come into our city and build on land that was meant to the main office base
The applicant claims that a certain amount of land will be placed in two conservation
But there's no guarantee on that
This proposal is inconsistent
with the city general plan
which was adopted by
was was adopted to protect designated open space and
guide response of responsible development
Changing this land to commercial use undermines that plan and weakens it purpose
Once this land is
We
Designated for commercial use there is no going back this
That decision will permanently change the area and set presidents for future projects
Uh, please don't let uh, please don't let this become another communal riel
Project. I urge you to vote no on this project. Thank you. Thank you
Scott Smith. All right. And after that will be Patrick
Rylan
Go ahead. Hi. Good evening. Uh council and uh, mr. Mayor
Um, I do live in the area. I live in eastville. Um, I know I'm not a
You know community member here in harupa valley, you know, and I listened to the comments online social media
Uh, the comments from everybody that you know opposes the project and I do have sympathy for them
But as a local neighbor, I say the benefit of this project and I do support it
Um, I think that if we look at the facts
Of what the developer has done the due diligence the studies the information that the gentleman talked about
No significant
Damage to this area
Because of this project so I would encourage the council to please consider the facts that have been presented on record
And vote yes for this, uh, project. Thank you. All right. Thank you. Uh, patrick
rylan
Come on up sir after that will be
Oh, this is a toughie for me
I'm going to I'm going to look at this for a few more minutes. Will you go ahead?
I don't live in rivermen. I live in harvests villages up the way
But after seeing everything and hearing everything and hearing the proposals
Uh, I I you know, I agree with this to go forward. Uh, it's you know, it's his
Inalienable right of his pursuit of happiness to develop this on his land
And if this is part of the thing that he's going to get with his land, that's his inalienable right
We may not like it. It may be an eyesore, but that's part of our bill of rights
And so if he wants to do that in his pursuit of happiness
He has every right to do so. Thank you. All right. Thank you
All right, uh last name dale first name not sure
Come on and and
How is the name pronounced the first name?
Say again
Okay, you can understand why I had a little hesitancy to try
Okay, so we'll move along
um
to let's see
Tonya
That's
So you're good. Okay, perfect. Thank you
And then uh, I have a melony no last name
All right, and after that I have an amber
Amber here
Okay, so next
Good evening mayor and council members. Thank you for the opportunity to speak
My name is melony Deutsch and I am here to respectfully oppose the proposed discretionary
Resoning of the conservation land currently designated as open space and flood control
This parcel is not vacant or underutilized land. It serves a critical public purpose
It is part of an active flood basin adjacent to an established residential neighborhood
Its current zoning reflects that reality and protects both
Nearby home homeowners such as myself and the city itself
Resoning this land for commercial use specifically for storage units and rv raises serious concerns first
flood safety
Flood basins exist for a reason altering land use in a flood-prone area
Increases runoff reduces water absorption and shifts flood risks
Onto surrounding homes and other areas that are not equipped to carry that burden it would cause
Even with mitigation measures development in these areas often transfers risks other than eliminates it when flooding occurs
It is residents not the developer who bears the consequence
second
RV and storage facilities are inherently commercial and industrial and character
They bring increased traffic noise lighting visual impacts and crime
This site directly borders a housing community that was developed with the expectation that this land would remain forever
conserved and protected not
commercialized
third precedent
This is a discretionary rezoning of conservation land approving it sends a message that protected land can be reclassified in harupa
Valley whenever a commercial proposal is deemed convenient that undermines the long-term planning public trust and the integrity of the city's general plan
fourth
limited public benefit this proposed
Facility has minimal employment limited economic activity and no meaningful community amenities in exchange residents
Are asked to absorb the increased risk reduced quality of life and permanent loss of conservation land
This is not a question of opposing development in general. It's about appropriate development in appropriate locations
The location proposed for the rezoning is not that keep it as it is as conserved land for us residents of harupa valley and the river bend community
Conservation land and flood control areas exist to protect people property and the city's future resilience
I urge the council to uphold the current zoning deny this discretionary rezoning and affirm each of your commitments to public safety
Responsible planning and the residents who rely on those protections. Thank you for your time and consideration
I'm near a shory and then radrigo munas
Hello everyone, uh, my name is amira shuri. I live in the river bend community and i'm totally against this project
What I do for living is i'm an online retailer. I am currently leasing nine different storage units
There is around us within like 10 miles radius area. There is eight different storage locations
They're all fired for my business because they all have empty space
During the last meeting, uh, I provided a screenshot from one of their software
Showing they had only 52 occupancy of the one that I am in they had 48
Percent of their units
They're the vacant they're ready to be leased
What i'm trying to say is the community and the citizen of the city does not need another storage unit there is plenty
For the rv storage
There is literally one that's less than two miles away on the other side of the 15 freeway
Right next to the silver lakes. So there is really no need for excuse me another one
Uh
When you're going on the 15 north
You're gonna look and you're gonna see a sign that said welcome to europa valley
When you look to the right you're gonna see a very nice beautiful
uh
Open area and you and they want to change there and put a junkyard where i have like those ugly rv's and
This makes no sense to put there in the community that you know, we don't need it. We don't we just don't need it
Another thing I really want to say is there is they said the entrance of this
Project is
2000 feet long
And that's all
Behind their houses like they're literally behind everybody's bedroom
And then those trucks and those rv coming in and out every day from 8 a.m. To 11 at night every day seven days a week
Why we don't need it
I really encourage you guys to vote no on this. Thank you so much
Rodrigo units
No, red regal last call
Okay
That's fine
All right, next is Blanca Munos
Same last name probably left together. Okay. And after that is Thomas
uh
Do not Tony
Probably screwed that up but
First
Wow, I got to say I mean I love this
We're all in the world. Do we get to everyone gets to voice their opinion and you get to do that
That's pretty cool kids here showing props. I mean, I love that part of this stuff
Mr. Corona, I got to say my heart's with you as a guy who personally has been responsible for literally thousands of bags of trash
Out of the river walk trails. I mean a lot of people here just I mean even though they live here
They have no understanding what's down there our biggest challenge right now isn't just pulling trash out of there
It's the very expensive gloves I have to buy
And the limitations on the kids that I can now bring there because of the needles and the fentanyl problems because of the unhome population
The illegal drug use and all the stuff that happens down there and you know a lot about that because you're helping to clean it out
I've gotten to the point that I'm very limited on the people
That I can bring down there and what we can do
um, I can tell you that I have pulled many bags of trash out of the area that's being considered now
and um
It's been really painful over the years that area right now. Whatever it is. I mean
the developers plan I'll leave that to the people here
but
It's a trash dump. It's been a trash dump for a very long time
It was worse before you got here, but even still and like you said
Came across the bridge. There's the homeless encampment. I just want to shake my head
Right like something has always needed to be done with that
The crime that happens there the dumping that happens there the trash that's there guys like me or the ones that pick it up
And I guess now he's doing it
Okay, we've done it for years and nothing's happened and I know everyone has
uh, not in my backyard mentality and believe me, I respect that
Okay, but I'll tell you something people in my group know about
cleaning up trash
And finding places to park trailers. Okay, that's something I know a lot about
And there's not enough of it and I wish there were and I wish
We could all have like that like a harry potter thing with the magic place that we could hide all the stuff
We didn't want it was really close so we didn't have to drive very far and you couldn't there's a sound barrier and you can't do it
But it doesn't we need stuff that's close
And we need stuff that you can't really see and in all due respect
I learned a lot tonight. I really appreciate staff because there was stuff I didn't know
um, but
I look at this and I like the guy goes out and buys 87 acres with the intention of donating
You know 73 acres to conservation makes the agreement to work all this stuff out
And now the people saying that he's taken away from conservation land
I don't know. It's kind of like reading the end of the book without reading the beginning of the book
But whatever you guys do, um
We need more storage whether it's here or someplace else and we need someone to gate that place off
Provide security and keep it clean for the community for everybody because they're right their kids don't need it
We don't need the unhome population there. We don't need the encampments
They don't need needles and they don't even want to know what fentanyl does to kids so quick
So whatever you do, please do something that resolves it, but I like what's happening. Thank you. Thank you
Next speaker is here malek
Leave, okay. Next after that is george morrow. Oh, it looks like morrow. Maybe not
moron
Is there a george here
No
All right jackalin moron
Probably also left
Uh, okay. Jasper
Sharma
No
Okay, run anderson
Ron, I see ron. There he is. Who mar you just pop which one just pop
Okay
All right, you may ron hang out for just a few more seconds. All right, go ahead ma'am
Hi, my name is just fall and uh, I agree with opposing the development of this
Um, one of the things that I heard that I'm most concerned about is this ai technology with the cameras
um
No one asked and no one answered
How do we know they're going to limit it to
the um
Storage facility in the areas when there's kids in the neighborhood people coming in and out
Like someone mentioned this facility is right behind people's bedrooms. Um, I don't know if the developer is offering
um more security or more
privacy provisions to
the neighbors. What is the developer offering to the neighbors in some type of, uh, uh, you know
consideration for
uh ripping up the land in the back and
uh going through
Conservation land and why are the why is the conservation agency not here?
How can we are not hearing from them?
Um
This these are just questions I have
um, I think that
Information presented is not sufficient, uh, for me as a neighbor to say
Uh, I approve of this building so I would appreciate your consideration in opposing the development of this unnecessary project. Thank you.
All right, very good. Now ron come on up
All right ron and oldie but a goodie
Yeah, I didn't think I'd make it this long
common
Yeah
Uh, mr. Mayor honorable council members
Good evening, I'd be remiss if I didn't uh, say hello to my old friend peter thorns and he's uh
He's been a pillar of this community as an unresident for
Since before the city was incorporated
You all have a lot to be appreciated for
um
I don't have a dog in this fight
My concern is the process
I think there are a couple of people that there were opponents of uh
this ordinance or this uh
bill was uh
Kind of uh, make in my argument. We're talking seven years as is going on
Some of you weren't even on the board at that time
You know
I was involved with many other individuals than the
Establishment of the city getting it on the ballot to become
the last city in
California to may very well be the last city in california
One of the things we tried to do was eliminate
politics
bureaucracy that we were seeing with the county
We wanted to make it easy for
People to come to the community and want to invest their money and help us grow
And it seems like more times than not, uh, I'm not going to
Save it right or wrong or who's at fault, but we seem to discourage people
I mean here's a project that's been going on
Like I said for six or seven years
uh
They
Thought here a second they can't
No, I'm talking about a senior moment. I apologize
Uh
Lost all my train of thought well the
The proponents of the project he came here in good faith
to uh invest his money
put in a meaningful project
And we've taken his money for the last seven years
whether it was directly to the city or other agencies and we just uh
Do not seem to have any concern for the time or the money that they invest
he's got
Hundreds of thousands of dollars probably invested in this program
They've been negotiating with the city for seven years and it looks like the last minute. We're going to
That sorry run end. Yes. I'm sorry. That's okay. It's very nice to hear from you though
Next speaker is gerry connor
Gary you're up. I got your speaker card in my hand
After that will be uh
she and wang
Okay, I'll be brief
But first I would like to appreciate the city council for their unanimous vote last month
To impose some restrictions on how ice operates on our city
You were the first in the inland empire to do so and I thank you for that
So that I'd throw that in
uh regarding the development of the storage center
Uh, this parcel is a water course watershed and conservation area and should stay that way
The general plan includes an equestrian lifestyle overlay and a san anne river corridor overlay and these open spaces
Need to be preserved
not rezoned to commercial retail
And that the developer is using intimidation and bully tactics
Like threatening councilman carmona with litigation if he doesn't recuse himself from voting simply because he asked questions
About this project should be enough to deny their petition
It is insulting and demeaning and should not be tolerated
Similarly this project which intrudes into the wildlife corridor at the san anne river bottom
Should not be tolerated either. I asked that the city council denied this rezoning. Thank you
Good evening. My name is chen wang
I myself with my wife here brandy
We've been residents of a harupa valley since 2004 when it was called me or loma
I'm here to speak in favor of the project
And i've heard many of the residents of the river bin and I appreciate your comments
Um, I was here before that was even all built. It was third law when I move here
um, you know, I hear their concerns, but
Whatever development it is in this case is a storage unit
It's not just I know like they don't want it in the backyard. They don't need it many residents says they don't need it
But other people do
Is not just there for them
you know, um
I'm also a member of the um group of alleys chamber
And many of my uh friends at the chamber are small business owners home-based
They need storage units and I heard people saying oh within 10 mile radius
You want to drive 10 miles to go pick up two boxes to ship
I don't think so for small business people, you know, that's that's a lot to ask, right? So people need convenience
I'm going to retire in about five years. I'm looking to buy brand new rv
And looking for storage is one of my big concerns. There's not enough rv storages
Near where I live. I live by the way 10-minute walking distance. I don't live in river bin
I live in uh township
10-minute walking distance to the proposed project
So for my house probably like closer than some of the river bin people because if they live on the other end
They're actually farther to the project than I am
So I think um what I like about what I heard today is that uh once this uh project is approved
The swarm is going to take over the responsibility of maintaining
That's professional management and when I saw the picture of all the homeless people
I know every time when there's some commercial development
Those homeless people just get disappear. I don't know where they go
But when there's like nobody there just bunch of uh
They can land
They they and I feel I feel for those people something should be done about that, right?
but um
Developed me in general once I see a shopping center go up like a storage unit go up
The area gets improved by the developer. There's like sidewalks and so forth. So in short
I'm in favor of this project. I know people against it are more passionate
But the people that are for it are usually not as engaged
I'm here to tell you that I support this project. Thank you. All right. Thank you
Next is uh Richard Lynch
Is Richard still here?
I think he is not here. So move along to brandy franks
One
Okay, very good. Thank you
and
next is
Miguel Garcia
Miguel
I see somebody running. Here we go. It's your turn, sir
After that will be hello to uh meggy brown after you
Hello to everyone. It's always good to see you guys. My name is Miguel Garcia. I'm a resident from harupa lolli
Um, I'm a driver of the contractor
We driving always to la to and different counties to
get the
Food to our families on the table if we have an opportunity to
provide our families to their own economic
economic
Making an honor city
What why not? Um, so thank god we have the offer on the project
My company. It's a pacifici shirak
If you guys approve this project
We are going to take over the project and it's going to support the economy from my family
I live in shallow rock here in churupa lolli. I'm honored. I'm the hunter
Thank you so much guys. Thank you
Maggie brown
No, Maggie. Oh
There we go
Come on
And after you will be nadine
wahaba
Hi, I'm actually a resident of east fail, but I have clients and friends in harupa valley
And I agree with the previous two speakers. I do support this project
Um, I see a lot of RVs around that just really need a home and even though we have one on citrus and it's closed by
We need more
So I support the project. Thank you. All right
Nadine
Nadine still here. No
All right, uh christian
Scrange
Oh
Can they not hear me out there?
Hello
Okay, they're gone. All right. So no nadine no christina. How about uh jina?
Gracie jina grace
No
All right guy
spelik
Hmm. Oh, are you which one jina? I'm not guy. Selleck. No, uh, but okay jina. Okay. Thank you. Go ahead ma'am. Yes harupa resident. Thank you
I wanted to um speak here in strong support of tonight's um item
I want to be very clear approving the storage facility and the associated zone chains. It's not re it's not just reasonable
It is smart planning reasonable governance and exactly the kind of decision that keeps harupa valley moving forward
Instead of standing still a lot of the opposition we've heard tonight is emotional and not factual
So let's talk about the facts
First the claim to the storage facility where increased traffic or congestion simply does not hold up
Storage facilities are actually the lowest traffic generating commercial uses
They do not have shift changes delivery fleets or crowds
Compared to retail warehouses or industrial uses that are allowed under similar zoning this project produces significantly fewer trips daily
Second the idea that this will somehow hurt surrounding property values is not supported by evidence
In reality modern storage facilities are clean professionally managed well lit and highly regulated
These facilities typically have 24-hour surveillance controlled access and on-site management
There are far more secure than vacant lots or aging unused parcels full of drugs and crime
Same note to this project does not preserve safety. It leaves land underused unmonitored
Now let's talk about the zoning change itself
Zoning is not a sacred scripture. It's a planning tool
meant to adapt as a city grows and as it needs change harupa valley is no longer a small overlooked community
We are growing
diversifying and evolving
Refusing to update the zoning when a compatible low impact use is proposed is not preservation its stagnation
This project brings us a way to preserve our history
Minimal demand on city services and no strain on schools or emergency services
It is fiscally responsible and it supports our residents and our businesses who you heard tonight generally need this storage facility
So with that I just wanted to say kudos to the planning staff. You're in a very tough position
But this was good planning all the way around. Thank you. All right
Next speaker is is guy spellock still here. All right, perfect. Thank you for that. Next is Dennis Romeau
Dennis Romeau
and following that would be
Romy Romeau. So I'm thinking they're both left. Okay
Now robin kill point
and after that is patty
Hello, I am a resident of harupa valley. I am less than half a mile from the project and I so
Support the project. There are a lot of people from river bend that made their comments about how you're in my backyard
How we got rid of the pen that panoramic use and all that and how when I bought my property
there was no word of
Of a storage facility being in well when I bought my property in 2003 and I saw cows over there in a beautiful panoramic view of norco
I wasn't told river bend would be there when I looked to possibly invest in that property
I was told it was in flood zone. So I couldn't build there yet the value that people from river bend are all bent because this project is supposedly
being built on flood zone
Which it's going to be improving the property raising the property to be able to not be in the flood zone
They're complaining about fires. Well with this development the fire department will have more access to go behind river bend and actually put out fires
That could possibly come to river bend
Also, they're talking about
It's not safe. Well when I rode my horses over prior to river bend
When it was safe
It I wouldn't go out night because of course that wouldn't be safe because it was so dark
Well when river bend was built we were told that no
Yeah, all these people are going to ride their bikes and take their dogs and it was an equestrian trail
When I ride my horses over there the people of river bend whose backyards are actually not going to be facing
the project but they're going to be still facing the beautiful mountains that
They have blocked from the rest of the city
When I ride my horses back there, I get cussed at I've been yelled at
Why is your horses over here yet?
That's what that trail's supposed to be for not just for the dogs not just for the jogging
My children went to vandramolin. It is not a bunch of traffic over there
The traffic came because river bend was over there
My kids were going there before river bend was built
I go that back through there daily
And when I go through there is not a lot of traffic over there except when school gets in and when school comes out
um
Oh, and then there was somebody complaining that he has an storage unit and he doesn't want any more storage units
Because he doesn't like the competition. Well, of course who wants competition?
If you guy you own one restaurant have them forbid another restaurant comes into town
Because then you have competition. I thought that was the way of life in america was to be able to have competition
And I guess that's all I have to say. Thank you. I do support the project. Thank you
Patty 12 is patty 12 here. Thank you maria compass
Is
That maggie my apologies come on up maggie welcome. Thank you council
My name is maggie campos
And I am um
part of the
property management at bernala
I'm very involved with all of our residents there
um, I have
resident events there
I have had the pleasure of speaking with steve what his project
And I think his project would be a big
Big plus for us because we have a lot we have over
anywhere from six under to seven hundred
residents
Our problem that we have is we don't have enough storage space for our residents our residents are allowed one car
per lease holder
If they come in with two cars, they're going to need another spot
So I was talking to the residents. I think steve's going to be a great partner
For us and I
I'm speaking on behalf of a lot of our residents. They really want this project. They want to be able to
live in harupa
They want to you know, it helps with tax dollars into harupa. It's going to improve
The area right there because we have a homeless nobody can walk there. I mean
I think I drive by
As I'm from east vale, but I I've been working at the granola for
four years
I I really
Think that this is a very important thing for our residents. I support it
I think steve would be a great partner for the community and
helping out all right think oh, was that it? I don't want to cut you off if you weren't done
One left. Yeah, I wanted to say that
When granola was being built there was a lot of opposition
Because they didn't want the apartments there
We're here
We pay a lot of tax dollars here
Same with these bill. They didn't want walmart when walmart open up
All of east vale was there. So I welcome the self storage
I think people are opposed to it
But I think the people that are opposed to it are going to be the one they had the gravel grand opening
Thumbs up
All right next um
Martin campos after that is looks like Vanessa campos
Is that you? Okay, welcome
Good evening, good evening everybody. My name is Vanessa compost
Um, I have two friends who live in this area
I'm at my friend's house almost every other day. We walk to the parks around her neighborhood
Go on the trails which from what I've seen not many residents really walk on the trails
and um
Or I've seen them either near the trails
Me and my friends play batman tennis and basketball constantly in this area
Yes, we're still considered young and my opinion might not matter to some of you guys
But I do have a say in this too. I understand all your points of views and your concerns
But we have to understand change happens
The trail used to be a horse truck
Horse trail before the houses before the houses there was also tomato fields
I get changes scary, but we can't shun it away without coming up with options to accommodate to everybody's feelings
And understand every person's point of view. I vote. Yes. Thank you
All right. Thank you
it looks like
possibly
Anybody's name. All right
Next
Cody
Kate
Cody anybody named cody
Still here
No, okay
Uh, next is jaden zavala
He's okay
All right, and then after that is
Last name cabrera
I can't read the first name unfortunately somebody named last name cabrera
Left, okay
All right. Next is hank treva. All right. Thank you hank
All right
now
That is
I want to make sure in case I said a name and and it wasn't heard
Was there anybody who turned in a blue speaker card that still wanted to speak that hasn't been called
sir
And then ma'am
You come up first and then did you fill one of these out?
Okay, what's your name?
Ramirez, okay
And i'm a hoorupa resident for 29 years
Before any of this happened
Before the river van before anything I do ride my bikes and on the thing and
We used to ride through the river van and nobody said anything when it was constructed
Now that's one thing the second thing it is
Is that by building this place is going to be
A lot of the places don't have these places for the RVs or the extra junk
Instead of having them in all the houses
You're going to put them in one place is going to take away from the burden of the city
Ordinance and
Giving tickets because you're parking in the front and doing all this stuff. So it's just
Everything combined in one place
so instead of having
98 places that you had to go and give tickets to or
Move your trailer or the neighbors don't like it
Assisi 98
I wish it would be more
Because that way we don't have to worry about not having a place to put our stuff
What I have always
I mean, I've been looking at the hoorupa has been growing
Don't do don't do don't do but don't don't give us no
Places to do it
So it's it's really
Heartbroken that we came to a city and weaving
Part of it and instead of keeping us together is like no, you don't like it. I heard a lot of
people they have mixed
Because they don't like it because they don't need it
But there's a lot of us they need it
There's a lot of people that actually do need it and and they can call the city and say hey
This guy has an RV in front of the house
You don't have to worry about that because now it's going to have a place
98 of them I wish that in the future will be
500 of them so there's how many I really don't know how many people live in hoorupa valley
But I know that more than a thousand have an RV that is blocking somebody's view
So instead of saying we don't we don't want
Developments like this we should support them
So that way you can continue growing and be a cleaner city
Instead of everybody having our home and everybody calling because they're breaking the
Ordinance now, which it wasn't before because it used to be a horse properties now. We cannot even have have a
RV in the front of the house or
a horse trailer because the neighbors because they come from other cities
Now they're become carans and they don't like what we had here before so
These projects help them
not to call the city for stupid reasons
and and it supports people that actually needs these places
to actually
Have a place to to store things that we have
So I support this project since the beginning I support anything that makes hoorupa valley
Girl for the best now for opinions but for the growth of the economic
And the well being for all of us now for a few for all of us
Thank you, sir
And there was one other
And what's your name, ma'am?
Sarah what?
I probably got it pretty close, but I'm not going to tell you what it was me earlier when you were confused
I was like, oh, oh, probably that's why I asked if there was cards because I I do screw up names and not on purpose
But it happens
Live in river bend
I agree with all my neighbors. I'm just worried if it's so easy to change
the zoning
How much more of this zoning are we going to change all along the river bed?
Is my only concern and there's got to be other commercial areas that it can be built
I understand that people need storage, but there's got to be other commercial areas if they can do their storage units
And that's it. All right, thank you
All right final call any other public comments? I think we've probably called everybody who's here. So
That was a fun experiment with 50 plus speaker cards
All right with that we get to move back to a five-minute rebuttal
Which the developer has five minutes to answer whatever they choose to answer pertaining to this
So you may begin whenever you're ready
Good evening honorable mayor and members of the city council. My name is kelly black
I'm from fennimore and i'm working with steve galves and i'm very proud of that fact
Tonight I have a theme
It's my favorite song
It's called let the truth be told
And that is what I am going to do tonight
I am going to tell the truth because you deserve it
I deserve it and your citizens deserve it
To be good. I want to talk about some of the things that we've heard about tonight
There were a lot of speakers. Usually I try and go through by name
I don't have enough time to do it, but I've broken it down into a couple of major themes
The first is rezoning and development on a floodplain
How many of you remember what river bend was zoned?
W-1
How many of you remember what river bend was?
It was a floodplain
River bend was built by I believe linar don't quote me on that
And one of the first things linar had to do was raise it out of the floodplain
So you're concerned about rezoning setting a precedent that precedent has been set
And it's been set by many of the residents who are here tonight
The second thing safety and security
This project introduces eyes ears
And electronics to a place that doesn't have it right now
There are no cameras
There are no eyes
There are no gates that are controlled for access
All of that will come with this project
Anyone who knows development knows that development brings eyes
And it creates less of an attractive nuisance for people who want to do bad things and not be seen
What are the other major concerns we heard tonight was traffic and noise
This project creates 220 trips total
the I-15
Which is a 24-hour a day seven day a week road that is immediately adjacent to river bend
152,000 trips a day
That is trucks
That is commercial vehicles
24 hours a day
The noise in river bend right now
Is so loud that the project noise
Actually doesn't even register
And that is in the mnd
The ambient noise levels at river river bend are in the 60 decibel range
The project noise generation conservatively is in the 44 decibel range
conservatively
Our mnd estimated that there would be a one decibel difference
Between the existing condition
Sorry fly lawyers attract them apparently
Between the existing conditions and the project after conditions
In order for noise to be perceptible to the human ear
You have to have a three decibel change and that is part of the mnd
I want to turn now to some of the things that i've seen on social media
And yes specifically i'm looking at you councilman karmona
And all of your posts you started posting in july of last year you had one in july july 9th
You had two on november 12
You had one this year in january
Which was actually two because it was on your stories and you had the poll and then you had the result to the poll
And then you've had two more one on february third and one surprisingly while you were in a study session tonight
Which i thought was interesting
I want to go to some of the things that you've raised in your
hosts
And i would point out that you had a meeting with mr. galvez on november 19th of last year
And i'm curious to know why
All of these questions weren't asked at that meeting
Why are you asking them now?
Resolution calls for 14.27 acres when only six acres are developable
Are slited for development you cite my letter my letter, which is in your packet. I believe it is in page
I want to say
261 of the full agenda packet full agenda packet being
511 pages my letter starts on page 261
You cited on page two to where i say it's six acres
You didn't highlight the full sentence which i thought was curious because the full sentence is
Construction of the project will result in a development footprint of approximately six acres. All right. Unfortunately time is up. Thank you
All right. Thank you. Okay, so i'm available for questions. Yes. Thank you very much
All right now
That the public's had a chance to weigh in
Council is going to deliberate and
Potentially has the ability to ask questions of staff or the developer. So I will
Take a guess that this side is going to have some questions
No, I don't have questions. I'm ready to deliberate questions questions for staff any questions for staff for the developer
Okay
Do I need to before she asks questions to the
That's what i'm okay
All right
Thank you. So my question well, thank you for everybody for their comments and saying again this late with us
my question is
Whether we vote yes or no on this project will the conservation
Still continue maintaining the property up to the Santa Ana river bin
Good evening again kelly black as we've talked about
The ownership of the property is currently with swarma
Section 2.3 of the purchase and sale agreement with swarma
Requires the deed back of approximately at the time it was thought to be 15.6 acres
We actually know now it's 14.29. Thank you very much to surveying and some more precise mapping
So approximately 4.29 14.29 acres will come back to mr. Galvez
That comes back regardless of if this project is approved
What needs to be approved for that to come back and why swarma currently owns all of the property is because the parcel lines are not
Divided in a way that separates out effectively the 72.5 acres that is conservation
From the 14.29 acres that is the development
So then why not just ask for the lines to be changed instead of asking for everything to be rezoned we
So I want to make it clear we are only asking to rezone the 14.29 acres of development property
We are not asking for the full 86 acres to be rezoned nor are we asking for a general plan amendment over the full 86 acres
Correct I understand that so why why only why did we not ask for a lot line adjustment?
Which is what we actually we originally did ask for that
And we were told that it would be more efficient and it would be better if we did a tentative parcel map
A tentative parcel map is a project under sigma
So we had to bundle that with our cup
With our general plan amendment and with everything else and that is why you have it before you tonight
We need to have a parcel map in order to make those transfers happen
Okay, and then you're asking that six acres is what's going to be developed
The the full development acreage site is 14.29 acres of that six acres is going to house the building
And the rv storage
Four acres will house the borrow area what we call the borrow area
That's where we are going to get the dirt to raise up the six acres for the development
And that is where we are also going to have our stormwater filtration
The rest of the acreage is the road
And then what we haven't talked about tonight is there is actually some sensitive habitat in that 14.29 acres
There's approximately 0.3 acre
Of sensitive habitat that habitat is going to be preserved
We are required to preserve it. It was required under our JPR
And we are conditioned to preserve it
So if you are if 0.3 needs to be preserved but you're going to be moving dirt in that area
No
We are we are not going to be moving dirt in the 0.3 area. The 0.3 area is outside of the borrow area
It's outside of the development area. So one of the first things we will do is we will fence off
that 0.3 acre area
You will fence it off. Okay, and my question is why not just
Ask the zoning for what you actually need why not like why the whole 14
I understand you want dirt but you can get dirt from anywhere and it doesn't have to be rezoned
So a couple of reasons for that number one we and this was talked about at the planning commission
We have to rezone the whole 14 acres because we can't do a borrow site
On land that is zoned as open space
So we need to rezone it to do the borrowing from there
Why are we borrowing soil from there as opposed to bringing it in off site from off site number one
That would be a traffic impact that would also be an air quality impact
But number two and more importantly if we take soil from the site
As it is now
We are lessening the risk of importation
Of invasive species
Or importation of bad soil
We know what we have on that site now
Why wouldn't we use our good soil that has a good seed base
to fill in the site
Why would we create more trips when we could just take the soil that we have from this area that's already disturbed
And create the development pad that we need
Okay, now is there a possibility that once you use your dirt and let's just say you build your storage
Can you give the risk of that acreage back to conservation?
We can't because it has to be our stormwater infiltration basin
What we did offer at planning commission and we are still offering it tonight is we are willing to put a deed restriction
Over that borrow site so that it can only be used for stormwater infiltration
And disbursement and it can't be used for anything else
My other question is you mentioned linar had um built
um river bend
if
Why
Why didn't linar just build all the way up to the property where to your property line that you have now they didn't acquire it
They didn't acquire it now
Is did they not acquire it possibly because of the same issues that it was in
Flood zone that it was part of the senate and all of that
Is that why they didn't build because looks like the property could have been built all the way up to the senate and a riverbed
Right it could have been I can't speak to why linar didn't I can only tell you this
Mr. Galvez is the third owner of this property
He bought it from a long time resident. I don't know why that resident didn't sell to linar
He chose to sell to mr. Galvez
Okay, thank you appreciate the information. Thank you. All right. Thank you. We'll let you know if there's any additional questions
I can run back up. Okay, and
Questions for you. Just one. Yeah, I can um
I have a question
Well, it might be might be for staff. It might be for them, but um
I think one of the things is is kelly just confirmed that this would take it out of conservation
So I think that's good to have um, but my my point on 2.3
And peter. I don't know if you've read 2.3 of the agreement or if we have because I don't see
Where do they say that this property would go back the 15 acres would go back?
Um, how does that work kelly because I see that it says 15.6 acres that you're going to delineate those 15.6 acres
Um, but specifically establishing ownership
You know, you can help me read this here. I'm happy to answer it if you'd like me to
Section 2.3. You'll see a line. It is uh, let's see. I'm looking one two three four about five lines down
And it has in bold exhibit c that's the end at so the end of the sentence is exhibit c attached here too
the next sentence
After the close of escrow the parties that is swarma and mr. Galvez
Shall cooperate at mr. Galvez expense
Mr. Galvez was the seller to delineate the property from approximately 15.6 acres
We now know it to be 14.29 of non habitat portions of the full site
in quotes the upland parcel
And to establish easements for two access points to the property lot line adjustments
buyer shall deposit to escrow a grant deed
pertaining to the upland's parcel to the seller
in the form attached as exhibit deed
and upon proof of
recordation of the lot line adjustments in the official records of the riverside county
escrow holder shall record the upland's parcel grant deed in the official records of riverside county
Got it. That's clear. I have a couple questions for mr. Galvez if you don't mind. Thank you. Kelly
Is mr. Galvez would approach please
so um kelly's right we we had a um
A conversation. I didn't remember the date. So thank you heli November 19th
Um, I remember that conversation
I was in conference room vb and in case you all are taking note
Um, and it was a very friendly conversation. I heard you had a you know, we talked we shook hands
Lots of smiles and we talked about the history. Right is that correct? I agree. Yes. Good conversation. Um, so
So it was it was very interesting this last friday
To receive a letter from you and your attorney
Saying that you didn't want me to participate in this meeting
Uh in that letter you threatened to sue the city of group of valley
If we didn't comply with your demands to to uh do a zone of change and a general plan amendment
Uh, do you stand by by that decision?
You know when I saw all the posts i'm not on social media facebook instagram
I just don't do because all of those videos that kelly cited
Um
Were posted before that conversation and never never I was hoping you would bring it up
What happened? I would you're the urge, uh author of those posts. I was hoping that you would bring it up. You didn't
So I left it alone
So
You waited two months to issue a legal letter
Uh, um, so it's interesting because I read the letter. Um, I don't I don't know. Oh, what was that?
Somebody just said answer. Oh, yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. Yeah. Um
I saw the additional post mr. Carona and I just got nervous that I wasn't gonna get a fair and open earring
That's all
That that that was it. That was it. That was it. That was it. It took a lot of deliberation for me to
Have the attorney write that letter because I didn't want to do it
But I just felt that with all of the posts that I saw that people were showing me
I was worried about just getting a fair honest and open hearing. You were concerned about the comments and the yes, sir
And uh, a disagreement that has nothing personal. It's nothing personal. Absolutely. Nothing personal
I don't have questions for you kelly. Uh, mr. Steve. Yeah, but uh, unfortunately
Council's direction. So please, um, so mr. Steve
I read the letter
And and it was very interesting because your attorney it wasn't kelly. It wasn't kelly. Uh, miss amber maupe
Uh, she cited four case laws one was
Break some break zone billards versus the city of intura where an i alcohol license was denied
Um, they didn't do proper noticing
Um, you also cited
Nasha llc versus the city of los angeles. That's a housing project
Um
That you know, we know how housing is playing out in core right now
And then you also cited nightlife partners
Versus the city of everly hills. That's a strip club that wanted to continue operating and was denied as well
But and so so I guess that's the company you're you're looking at
Um, but you also cited horn versus county of intura, which is was a subdivision
Issue that was improperly noticed
You got it. I'm sorry. Yeah, no, no worries. Um, the main one that was the main one that you cited
Um, specifically
That case is whether a county subdivision approval which was accompanied by a sequel negative declaration
Violated in adjacent property owners
constitutional due process rights by failing to provide adequate notice
And an opportunity to be heard before final approval essentially there was a project that was approved
And the neighbors sued the city or the county of intura and and the developers they won
Uh, because they found discrepancies in in the in the noticing
Mistakes that we've found in in your process as well. Um, and so I'm just wondering you cite that case
But it might be more that case might be more helpful to our neighbors who are concerned about this
So you're wondering
You tell me that you cite that case. It's my the turdie side of the case
Who you approved it? So so well, maybe you need to rethink the attorneys that that you have come i'm wondering
Yeah, and I you know
Do you
Is this a regular thing?
Do you regularly regularly threaten people with litigation if they disagree?
I have never threatened anybody in 30 years of real estate history
Have threatened anybody with litigation. Have you ever told anyone in this community that can you keep it to
Where we're at, please I can
Um in that case, that's that's the end of my questions. I appreciate your time. Mr. Steve. Okay. I appreciate you as well
Thank you. All right. Thank you
other questions comments
deliberation time
Opinions
Oh, that's true. Let me close the public hearing public hearing is closed
Uh now we get to make a decision
Anybody want to make a comment? Sure. I'll make it Chris
If you don't mind. Yeah, I can jump in
I'm on the move. All right. Um, so one I I think um
You know, Kelly made an excellent point
If if it's true and I haven't checked the zoning but you you seem to to confirm it that river bend was zoned w one in another time
Um, and so my question and is when will this stop?
Right because this this is zone w one. It's open space
Um
Uh, it's zoned open space. So my one of my biggest concerns is that this just continues and continues
Because there will always be another one that says well
The other part used to be zoned and we changed that so
Um, I wouldn't want to set that
Continue setting that precedent. Um here in this community, especially for this type of area
Um
There was a comment earlier
That said that it's
Someone said that it's his land and he should he has the inalienable no inalienable right to do what he wants with it
Um, but we've also we've confirmed that it's not his property
Right now, um, it's it's warmest property. It's in conservation. We'd be pulling it out of that
Um
The the framing
That they bring to our zoning calling it aspirational. I think it's concerning
Um
Yes, it's aspirational, but it's also very practical. It's also very specific and what we're defining this area
Uh to be and which is it's open space. I think it should be remained at as open space
Um
I think that my other two there's also a comment about if we're not building
We're we're not growing we're standing still why I like standing still and if you go stand still in that area
It is a beautiful site
Um, but my two my two biggest concerns is the gpa the general plan amendment
Um, which would basically permanently make it into commercial
Uh, see one cp
Outside of what this storage unit is
Um, we we don't know if that's what's going to be built
We don't know if if
If if if that project falls through if the if this land gets sold
It still remains c1cp and perpetuity that that's the zone unless that gets changed later on
and so
Um, in addition to the zone change that becomes permanent as well
um
So we're not opening it up to just this storage unit
We're opening it up to everything that's allowed within c1cp
So we have to consider that in addition to that
Knowing how the state is aggressively pursuing
commercial properties, um and and other sites that that to allow
Um
State backing and in building outside of municipal ordinances
I think I think it's just a major risk and I don't see the upside for our residents and for here people here in our community
Finally, um two things one. We talked about fires
And how this would help prevent fires
A couple days ago. I think I'll hear in rubin on mission boulevard. Um, we had a major fire in a self storage unit
Um, there was an explosion. I don't know
There you go. It was a major explosion major fire people
I don't know if they were living there if they were cooking drugs what was going on and so
You know, I think if we're trying to prevent fires, I think our firefighters are doing a great job
Um, and and we need more conservation space not less
Um
And those are my comments for now
Okay, chris. Sure. Um, I want to start off by being you know, I'm gonna try to be as concise as possible
Um as factual as possible and as objective as possible
Uh, I'm not against storage units
Um, as a matter of fact, there's about three of them that I know that are being proposed in other parts of the city
However, where they're located and it is important to me
Uh, yes, the facts are the nara had a raise a good portion of river bend out of the flood plane to build it
Uh to but we also learn how the the wonderful people have ever been without that growth is important, right?
The right kind of development is important again river bend in my opinion is a great community is a great development was worth
What was done to bring that out of the floodplain and gpa changed that
Uh, I think that this particular piece of land
Is not
I think where we've maxed out how far we should go the nara stopped for
Various reasons that if they ever want to share they can share
Um
The rest of it, I think should stay open space if mr. Galvez this sees other spots in the city that are more
You know prone to that kind of use
Uh, I think that he should pursue that
but right right now I have no reason to change more
of that w1 watershed. I think uh
Joe and i should have asked the question earlier, but swarma even if this does not get approved they have to maintain that area
Like that nothing changes. They have to maintain it and if they don't
We have code enforcement and for those of you know me. I love code enforcement
Um
Good or bad depending on what side of the
argument you are on the code enforcement at that time. So those are my comments. Okay
Look into my left ronika
um
So, you know
I was
Looking at all of the emails that we received. I've been taking notes on everybody's comments and listening to everybody
um
the biggest thing that I that I heard and I agree with is
Is um not changing the zoning and I think that that's really important
um
Me personally, I live in a community that um was owned by county
I have no streetlights in my community at all and I love it that way
Because i'm right next to the mountains. It's quiet
It's peaceful and I could only imagine what some of the neighbors when they're looking outside of their windows from their homes that they see no lights
It's peaceful. You may be here the crickets. You probably see a you know
A coyote here and there. You see the owls. That's the beauty of us living here in harupa valley and the folks that live here
That's what attracts us and that's what's going to keep us here in generations to come
so
I I my my biggest thing is like I said, I'm listening to the community and I hear you. So thank you
Um
Thank you very much all for being here tonight. So I'd like to try to remain consistent
Um, you know for the last several years. We've had many projects come through our city that put us between a rock and a hard place
And in this situation, they don't have us that way
um
I I look when I look at projects. I think of what are the community benefits?
What are the tax revenues? What are the jobs? What are the trade-offs for?
Changing the zone whenever zone needs to be changed
um
For the community benefit. I really don't see it. I don't see they're getting a benefit other than
You know profits will go to the property owner, right?
um
I don't see I know there's a need for storage and stuff, but
uh
a storage doesn't
Guarantee
The need is for that community. It's open for business to everyone. So I I don't use that as a as a as a
winning argument, right?
When it comes to storage units, uh, there's little to no tax revenue
Um, there's very little jobs. I so I just don't see the benefits in our community to have that trade-off. I don't see
How I can justify changing what our community has been asking for which is leave it alone empty space
To change it into something that can be
Impactful whether it's light or not. So I feel I've been very consistent throughout the years of looking at projects that way
And because of that, I I can't support this project
And I feel our community did come out and speak out and I feel
We did here tonight. So hopefully with that we can move forward with the what the vote
Okay
so
Thank you
Thank you to my council colleagues for uh for your
Comments, I will make mine short
Um, I want to say a couple things one. I'm not against storage units. I'm not against rv storage
Uh, I also did a quick google search while I'm sitting here tonight looking for other ones because somebody mentioned there was one just
Right around the corner. There are several right around the corner three in norco
uh more in group of alley
uh, and and I
You know even driving around our city. I've seen so many of them off of
At a wanda. There's some
uh, harupa road
There there are a lot of them now not all of them most of them don't have rv storage
Which would be the one thing that I would say okay. That sounds cool, but look
council has certainly
Already
Based on just the comments. I've heard over the last two minutes given me where this is going
Uh, so I'm not going to waste much time, but I did want to say one thing that that I thought was interesting
The vernola apartment person that that's I guess the manager there makes a comment about they don't have enough space for cars
They're only allowed one and and mr. Galvez is somehow going to be a help to them
But yet nothing in this says that people can park their cars
At all there is not even you know adequate parking for for that
So I don't know where that kind of concept was floated from it didn't make any sense to me nor would
Uh, you know, somebody wants to go get their car at midnight. Well, they're not going to be able to none of that makes any sense
It just so there are things about this that don't make sense. There are things that make perfect sense
But with with with what I think I now have heard I will go ahead and we will ask for a
A vote, but let me do it properly so we can get to it
Well, no one's going to motion a second to do recommendations. I can move that's why I want to do your thing
Yeah, I'll move I'll make a motion to I want to make sure before we do that because I have to read this out loud before that happens
I believe Peter
I have to call for a motion and a second to adopt resolution 2026-10
Sounds like is that five of you are opposed to the project?
So I think you can do it on one motion saying the proposed land use entitlements are denied
Okay, so can I have a motion that says that by somebody? Yeah, I'll make a motion a second
All all in favor to deny this is to deny. I'll make a motion to deny
Uh the land use application in this project. All right, or this second. Yep. Absolutely all in favor of that motion
I opposed abstention motion carries five zero. It is denied
We are moving to item 17 a appointment to fill an unexpired term on the planning commission
Uh, the city clerk Maria Morris. May we please have a staff report